so hello guys
today's webinar would mainly cover the
course content which we will be offering
from Jan next year
so the course is named as machine
learning in health informatics
we will be having two parts of the
course one is the theoretical
understandings followed by some Hands-On
training
so today the course content will be
covering mainly the topics and the
topics details which we will cover in
the coming
three months in the course
so just to introduce me I myself I am
trained at I was trained as a clinical
graduate basically a clinician then I
shifted my career towards the domain of
bioinformatics and health informatics
So I upskilled myself into the domain of
data and data data analytics and now
what I do is I combine multiple data
types to build predictive models ml
based models for a specific clinical
outcome
these covers use cases from the hospital
based organizations from the drug
Discovery companies
to the life insurance providers
so for today's webinar I have kept it in
three particular subsections first I
will cover the overview of Health
informatics which we will be teaching in
this particular course
then I will briefly work through the
types of Health informatics data and
lastly I will cover the case study
structure which we will be following in
the
course
so overview of Health informatics so the
first slide is how
informatics is transforming Healthcare
in this particular
stage of AI and machine learning
so as you can see there are mainly three
broad categories of Health informatics
the first is patient care
the next major thing is business process
and management the third one is drug
Discovery and
companies for pharmaceuticals
so for the domain of patient care
Health informatics can be used to solve
problems where we can manage efficiently
appointments clinical visits waiting
duration to the clinic we can have
precise diagnostics for particular
diseases we can prevent diseases by
detecting them at the earlier stage
one important thing is patient triage so
a hospital would be containing suppose
thousand patients we need to stratify
them into high risk moderate risk or low
risk and this Triad is very important
for patient care so this strategy is
also done based on informatics and
lastly Imaging and diagnostic
CT scan images extra images any
biomarker Discovery all these things
also falling under the purview of Health
informatics
for the business process and management
there is something called process
automation so in business so generating
business reports generating interactive
and flexible reports is something which
we are which is also a very useful use
case
claims Administration that involves
mainly predicting
the cost of or the burden of patient
or the high risk patients from the past
claims history medical claims history so
that that is very important from the for
the industry of healthcare claims
customer churn so what is the footfall
in your particular Clinic
when does the footfalls increase in
which month of the year
what are the factors that increases so
these things also fall in the purview of
business management then chatbot and
lastly business insights
for the drug Discovery companies or
Pharmaceuticals the majority is drug
Discovery so identifying drug targets so
by identifying molecular targets Gene
targets
planning Logistics planning and lastly
improving clinical trials so which
clinical trial how can we manage
clinical trials more efficiently so
these things fall under the purview of
drug Discovery and pharmaceuticals so
these are the major three three
Industries
well
the higher informatics is actually
transforming the healthcare
gradually